[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion
die entwicklungen der letzten zwei jahre
in der türkei haben nicht nur
auswirkungen auf politik wirtschaft und
das zusammenleben im land selbst sondern
auch auf türkisch stämmige männer und
frauen im ausland auch hier in der
schweiz
die gräben sind tief und gerade deshalb
wollen wir eine simple procontra erdogan
oder procontra islam diskussion
vermeiden
vielmehr soll es in dieser sendung darum
gehen die vielfältigen und komplexen
sachverhalte verständlicher zu machen
religion ist dabei ein faktor unter
vielen die relevante ist auch darüber
möchte ich mit meinen gästen sprechen
ich begrüße hier familienalltag sie ist
professorin für politische soziologie an
der universität basel
herr hafner hat die kopplung der ehren
präsident der wirt der vereinigung
islamischer organisationen im kanton
zürich und ebenfalls hier ist herthas
augusta schule er ist vorstandsmitglied
der basler muslim kommission herzlich
willkommen
ihnen allen feiert sie sind gerade eben
aus der türkei zurückgekommen was haben
sie erlebt worüber sprechen die menschen
es war ein sehr kurzer privater besuch
ja im augenblick spielt die
wirtschaftskrise eine sehr große rolle
die sehr spürbar eine wirkung auf die
bürgerinnen und bürger hat aber
natürlich nach wie vor ist die
zunehmende repression die zunehmende
einengung ein sehr sehr großes thema ich
habe viele kollegen in der und
kolleginnen in der wissenschaft die
derzeit verfahren haben oder ihren job
verloren haben
viele aktivisten die über zu
menschenrechten oder demokratisierung
gearbeitet haben sind jetzt sehr schwer
und repression ausgesetzt
und es ist natürlich dann doch immer
sehr schwer
dann trotzdem die türkei zu besuchen
also es ist nicht wie früher sondern ist
es immer sehr stark mit einem mulmigen
unguten gefühl verbunden
wohl wissend dass eben die kollegen die
freunde die bekannte doch wirklich sehr
schweren situationen ausgesetzt sind
er hat die profis das für sie
die häufig reisen sie noch in die türkei
seit 25 16 30 nicht mehr in die türkei
lebe ja seit 1973 in der schweiz
und ich habe immer wieder die türkei
besucht als ferienland kenne ich die
türkei aber eben in der schweiz hat man
sich irgendwie auf meinungsfreiheit sich
daran gewöhnt und wenn ich sehe was gut
ist in der türkei dann kommuniziere ich
spreche darüber
und wenn ich so etwas ist schlechter
schreibe ich oder kommen ziemlich das
auch und mittlerweile ist ist es
schwierig ein bisschen
regierungskritisch zu sein dann kann man
gleich geschafft werden das passiert
nicht nur was sage ich mal den türkisch
stämmigen sondern auch wirklich gut
ausländisch wir haben hier mehrere
deutschen die dann auch in den
gefängnissen sind für sie ist kritisch
wird die das land heute betrachten ja
herthas euro sie sind jetzt die jüngere
generation welche erfahrungen machen sie
mit ihren kontakten in die türkei
also meine situation das bisschen anders
in dem ganzen ich habe mein vater lebt
in der türkei also ich gehe immer wieder
mal besuchen
sonst habe ich so politisch also keine
repression zu befürchten jetzt eine
folge dass sie erwähnt haben
aber sie sprechen mit den leuten mit
ihren weiteren verwandten und bekannten
die sie in der türkei haben sprechen die
bei die lage dort oder ist das ein thema
das außen vor bleibt das navi
diskutieren also wir haben ja auch in
unserer familie unterschiedliche
meinungen zu der politik
es ist ja nicht so dass alle die gleiche
politische sicht begrüßen und
diskutieren aber ganz normal das ist
nicht so dass mir dass man seine meinung
zurückhält oder angst hat das
auszusprechen so ist das nicht so ich
liebe diese umzügen der meinung in der
türkei selber im typischen politik nicht
sie hat es eben angesprochen seit 2016
das heißt eigentlich seit dem
putschversuch und gehen sie nicht mehr
zurückgezahlt ist da doch noch zwei
wichtige abstimmungen folgt
frage und seither in der türkei gegeben
die eine war die referendumsabstimmung
über das präsidialsystem und da schauen
wir uns jetzt kurz einen an spieler an
was das konkret bedeutet die einführung
dieses präsidialsystems mit seiner
wiederwahl erhält erdogan durch die
einführung der sogenannten
präsidialsystems deutlich mehr macht als
präsident ist erdogan neu auch
regierungschef es gibt keinen
ministerpräsidenten mehr
neu kann erdogan auf seine minister ohne
bestätigung durchs parlament ernennen
als präsident hat der mehr politisches
gewicht kann eigene gesetze per dekret
erlassen und die aus dem parlament mit
seinem veto blockieren
und er nennt 94 mitglieder im rat der
richter einem wichtigen justizorgane ja
wie haben sie jetzt durch ihre kenntnis
der situation in der türkei wie haben
sie bereits die auswirkungen dieses
systems heute schon erfahren erwarte nun
der weg dahin ist natürlich nicht einer
der über nacht geschehen ist die sehr
rapide regression aus dem aus der
perspektive
demokratie ist ja schon in den letzten
jahren sehr stark zu beobachten gewesen
das war nun einfach jetzt der letzte
vollzug sozusagen der wechsel von einem
parlamentarischen zu einem
präsidialsystem ist natürlich nicht nur
etwas was setzt nur die abgeordneten
betrifft sondern natürlich ist ein
ausdruck einer ganz neuen phase in der
türkei die nun auf alleinherrschaft
beruht und wenn das führt dazu dass wenn
man zu denjenigen gehört die dieses
system gut finden oder auch den
derzeitigen alleinherrscher gut finden
wird das wenig auswirkungen
beziehungsweise positive auswirkungen
haben aber für diejenigen die das eben
nicht gut finden für diejenigen die die
parlamentarische demokratie beibehalten
wollten und auch von den maßnahmen von
den repressiven maßnahmen direkt
betroffen sind und da sprechen wir
wirklich von den regierungsgegnern die
in dem sinne 50 prozent also das ist ja
die türkei derzeit tatsächlich eine
gespaltene gesellschaft und 50 prozent
etwa die diesem system und diese
regierung zustimmen und 50 prozent die
eben dem nicht zustimmen und
das ist natürlich ein ganz großes
kernproblem was der tasche oder gerade
berichtet hat mag tatsächlich für einen
teil dieser gesellschaft zu treffen aber
für einen sehr großen teil eben auch
nichts
und für diejenigen die kritisch waren
und immer noch sind hat sich die lage
natürlich durch diesen neuen befugnisse
noch viel stärker verschärft und das ist
tatsächlich sofort zu spüren es gab auch
schon vorher sehr problematische
gesetzgebung die einschränkung der
meinungsfreiheit zum beispiel ermöglicht
hat aber die befugnisse die erweiterung
der befugnisse hinsichtlich der
opposition
ja die jetzt keine vetorechte mehreren
sozusagen die er das parlament das de
facto nur noch einen symbolcharakter hat
das ist natürlich eine ganz neue
dimension
was aus der perspektive europäischer
gesellschaften und vielleicht ganz
besonders auch der schweiz
doch irgendwo stutzig macht und auch
verwundert warum entscheiden sich die
menschen in der türkei doch zu einem
großen teil für die einschränkung von
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit und ihrer
politischen rechte wie ist das zu
erklären hier hatte ich denke das hat
auch mit der geschichte in die türkei zu
tun weil bis die akp regierung an die
macht kam waren die religiösen
praktizieren der leute das volk der
türkei als zweiter klasse leute
behandelt die hatten schwierigkeiten
gehabt in guten platz zu nehmen so
genannte weiß drücken die elite die
gesehen hat aber gesagt wir wissen das
beste wir machen das beste die gläubigen
die haben keine ahnung und während bei
spiegel zum beispiel im militärs wurden
die leute die religiös waren nicht
gewundert jedes jahr hat militär 150 2
300 leute ausgeschlossen
und weil sie nur williges praktizieren
waren und sie haben natürlich die
ausschluss waren nicht weil sie religiös
sind sondern die haben gesagt das
verhalten und was war was war das ganz
konkret was ist fast meinem vater
passiert der unteroffizier war ein
kommandant ein major kommt
während assenmacher sommers an und sagt
jetzt möchte ich die trinken und du
trinkst auch t
jetzt sagt ja ich fasse es jetzt ich
befehle dir was du und wenn er sagt
sorry weil muss ich dann nachträglich 60
tage fasten wenn ich bewusst
fastenbrechen mache ich nicht dann ist
er am nächsten jahr nicht mehr in der
armee oder das war s oder in anderen
bereichen
und dieses zweit kreis mensch zu sein
darunter haben sehr viele leute gelitten
und mit der akp war dieses zweite klasse
was man bürger zu sein wurde einmal
aufgehoben langsam und jetzt meine
mutter als frau eines berges offices
conti nicht zum beispiel in einem
militärspital in eingehen weil das in
relation von einem militärgelände war
weil der mann da vorne der soldat der
junge soldat gesagt hat sie dürfen nicht
hinein mit kopftuch geht ins spital
das ist auch ausdruck dieses strikten
laizismus wir kommen dann später noch im
detail auch auf diese frage zurück
gehabt das war dann so das heißt von
zweitklassiger plötzlich sollte man aber
wir sind auch wir gehören auch dazu
dieses gefühl ist sehr stark angekommen
eben bei 50 prozent der leute aber
leider das hat die leute dazu gefühlt
wenn solche worte dinge da sind aber was
ist dann mit den schlechten dingen an
die leute haben angefangen werden diese
errungenschaften alle anderen dinge die
sind schlecht gegenüber sehen
und das ist zu einer krankheit geworden
wir kommen darauf zurück sie sprechen
jetzt diese polarisierung an und diese
polarisierung die hat ja tatsächlich
auch rückwirkungen bis unter die
türkischstämmige bevölkerung in der
schweiz
wir haben dazu straßenumfragen gemacht
einerseits vor der präsidial abstimmung
aber auch eben schon zur
referendumsabstimmung und da schauen wir
uns mal an was die menschen auch so
gesagt haben also der waren ist für mich
der einzige wirklich darüber abstimmen
wie laut das ergaben bin halt von barßel
extra nach es ist eine große fortschritt
für die türkei und es sollte weitergehen
sich einig dass sie abstimmen
das ist wichtigsten uns beste was
richtig für das land ist weil man kein
einziger hersteller oder kein einziger
pass unserer heimat momentan wirklich
viele probleme gibt
ökonomisch politisch ich hoffe es ab 25
juni wird alles geändert
ja also die hoffnung des herrn zuletzt
die hat sich in dem sie nicht
bewahrheitet ich habe vor der sendung
auch mit zahlreichen türkischstämmigen
männern und frauen gesprochen und
praktisch alle ausnahmslos alle haben
mir berichtet von zerwürfnissen in der
familie von brüchen von freundschaften
bis hin zu ehescheidungen die durch die
spaltung durch die politik entstanden
sind wenn ich mir jetzt vor augen halte
wie wichtig im traditionellen türkischen
muslimischen verständnis familie ist
dann habe ich den eindruck dass sind
sehr schwere zerwürfnisse die hier
stattfinden wenn sie das so bestätigen
also ich kann jetzt so direkt nicht
bestätigen aber ich kann schon sagen
dass das ein angespanntes station ist
also man ist nicht mehr so offen
zueinander und mann verurteilt ein
anderer personen man geht auf die
argumente der gegenseite also ist
bewusst angebot nicht abkömmlich bekannt
man geht einfach auf die argumente nicht
ein
man hat auch kein verständnis für die
andere das allerschlimmste also dass man
einfach abblockt und den anderen dann
als seine schlechte personen oder ich
weiß auch zu als er in toller
unterhaltung ist schon waren das muss
schon zugeben
erleben sie das vereiteln ich denke
schon dass wie sieht es da schon dass
das zutrifft dass es eine sehr starke
polarisierung gibt die tatsächlich sehr
tief durch die gesellschaft geht und
auch soziale beziehungen im kleinen raum
auch beeinflusst die gesellschaft ist
tatsächlich so gestalten dass selbst
wenn personen einzelpersonen bestimmte
dienste aufsuchen zum arzt gehen oder
sonst ja also im alltag bestimmte dinge
sich erst mal informieren wo und zu
welchem politischen lager sozusagen
diese person gehört weil das den
vertrauensbruch ist natürlich so groß
und das ist natürlich aus einer
sozialwissenschaftlichen perspektive ist
das natürlich sehr fatal sich das
anzusehen wie was für eine
desintegration der zeit
in der türkei passiert und ich denke
auch dass es sehr hohe kosten geben wird
denn der graben ist mittlerweile so tief
und auch tatsächlich die fronten bildung
tatsächlich auch so stark dass ich im
augenblick sehr wenig chancen sehe wie
das friedlich sich weiter lösen wird
oder lösen gelöst werden kann also
selbst ein regime wechsel geben würde
wer wird dieser graben mehr trotzdem
nach wie vor vorhanden sein weil es eben
diese regierung schon so lange auch an
der macht ist und ihre eigenen
institutionen auch aufgebaut hat und mit
einem regime wechsel lösen sich
natürlich auch den befürwortern ja nicht
einfach nur in luft und wasser auf also
das ist die große frage wie kann
überhaupt noch gesellschaftliche frieden
herbei geführt sie beschreiben die
situation jetzt führt dirk heimlich den
aktuellen rahmenbedingungen aber wie
sieht es denn in den die us
gesellschaften aus in deutschland und
besonders auch ja da sehen wir sehr
deutlich dass natürlich diese wirkungen
seine sehr große strahlkraft auch auf
die schweiz aus deutschland und die alle
in österreich in einer anderen länder in
denen türkeistämmigen migranten leben
sehr stark haben also wir haben konkret
in basel die bespitzelungsaffäre gehabt
es gab versuche entführungsversuche man
sieht dass also der staat der lange arm
der staat es natürlich auch hier hinaus
greift und das löst natürlich auch
reaktionen aus ja und hier der
unterschied zwischen der situation in
der türkei und er ist das hier man dazu
zumindestens widerstand oder
oppositionen äußern kann daher denke ich
dass hier auch die polarisierung
insoweit eine andere ist weil sie
weniger angst haben muss sozusagen ja
also auch wenn natürlich diese angst mal
wieder zu wort gebracht wird dass man
sich nicht mal traut auf facebook
irgendwas zu schreiben oder wenn man in
die türkei reist ja dass man nicht weiß
was da passiert nichtsdestotrotz denke
ich dass hier die oppositionellen kräfte
einfach noch ganz alter grundbedingungen
haben als in der türkei und daher
während diese konflikte hier auch
artikuliert zumindest können sie auto
kollidiert werden
und solange sie eben nicht gewaltvoll
passieren und das ist ja auch zunehmend
er so denke ich dass das einfach auch
dazu gehört ja man ist ich finde es
nicht die journalistin rufen sehr oft
immer gerne dann an wenn es wieder eine
demonstration gab und dann ist immer die
frage kommt es nun zu einem bürgerkrieg
auf deutschen schweizerischen straßen
das ist glaube ich so eine sehr
verkürzte sichtweise man muss einfach
akzeptieren dass hier migrantinnen eben
leben und natürlich kriegen diese
migrantinnen auch mit was in der türkei
in den anderen herkunftsländern passiert
und dass sie sich damit
auseinandersetzen halte ich für sehr
normal ich finde das ein ausdruck auch
politischen partizipation swiss ja nur
in welche richtung das geht das ist
natürlich noch eine andere frage aber
ich halte es für seine wunschvorstellung
dass man denkt ja ja die die hier leben
die sollen sich überhaupt nicht mehr
über die türkei kümmern weshalb
eigentlich ja ich finde es ja schon ein
wichtiges thema was in der türkei
passiert also der zerfall der demokratie
ist auch doch wirklich ein großes thema
für alle
die europa leben er hat die prognos sie
haben hier im vorgespräch erzählt dass
sie ist etwa 2008 eigentlich ein
glühender befürworter waren von der akp
von dem programm dass erdogan für seine
partei rasiert hat und sie haben eben
gesagt das hat viel damit zu tun dass er
die religiösen die religiösen menschen
besser abgeholt hat als ich an hin
wie kam es dann dazu dass sie sich
zunehmend kritischer bis heute sogar als
gegner betrachten ja das problem eben
bis dann 2008
die nicht nur dass das entgegenkommen
gegenüber den gläubigen menschen
bevölkerungszahlen sondern auch
allgemeinen menschenrechte er hat sich
sehr stark an die eu an gelenkt und dann
gewisse gesetzesänderungen gemacht weil
sie eben menschenrechte meinungsfreiheit
und so weiter
immer wieder revidiert wurde und das hat
immer wieder positives zeichen gegeben
aber dann immer noch in diese zeit in
der bis 2008 hatte ja eher dünn gesät
seiner partei konnte zugemacht werden um
vom verfassungsgericht hat getöteten der
zweiten periode noch aber nachdem diese
hürde genommen wurde nachdem es gesehen
habt okay jetzt bin ich mächtig genug
leider der weg ist ein bisschen
abgedreht und dieses alleinherrschaft
ist mehr spaß im vordergrund getreten
und nicht nur wie ich kenne auch
abgeordnete von seinem umfeld bekannte
die dann immer wieder so genannte
berater gibt es aber man hört auf die
beratung überhaupt nicht mehr also immer
in eine richtung einer person und eine
andere mission ja sagen nein nein sagt
wir wären abgeknöpft
das hat sich dann eben verstärkt quasi
in die politik eingegriffen und wir
haben vorher eben verfassungsänderungen
und bahn jetzt an für sie die zwei
abstimmungen waren nur dazu da um was
erdogan faktisch vorher gemacht hat zu
legalisieren
er hat vorher immer wieder gesagt die
verfassung passt uns nicht mehr also als
zu eng gewordenen verfassung muss
geändert werden und er hat damals zu den
verfassungswidrig handlungen gemacht und
niemand hat er ihn zur rechenschaft
gezogen weil das war reden vor der
zweiten abstimmung der verfassung vor
drei wenn wir die aber zurückgehen hat
er sehr viele dinge gemacht hat gesagt
dass man konnte ihn nicht stoppen und
jetzt die zwei referendum und jetzt
waren ist nur legalisierung was es vor
fünf jahren zb gemacht hat
und das ist es also das heißt weg von
der demokratie weg von der
menschenrechte gedanken weg von der eu
also nicht nur ich sondern hat sich auch
für abschnitt bis und hermann hat sie
auch von der eu hat sich stark getrennt
oder verabschiedet und das alles aus den
gleichen gründen die menschen richte und
nun sage ich man die dinge so zu
gestalten wie eine einzige person passt
bringt schwierigkeiten ohne ohne
kontrolle
das heißt eben diesen drei teilen der
dreiteilung der macht legislative
exekutive judikative hat einen mehr
demokratie hat seine geschichte und
seine berechtigung aber jetzt wie wir
vorhin gesehen haben alle drei hängen an
eine person genau deshalb polarisiert
diese person natürlich auch so was mich
noch interessiert ist sie hat mir auch
berichtet dass sie als religiöser mensch
große erwartungen natürlich zunächst
einmal hatten in ein regierungsprogramm
und in eine person erdogan die sich eben
selber religiös auch gibt dass er seine
ausbildung als immer mehr kommt wirklich
aus diesem religiösen einfluss wäre wenn
man so will
was haben sie denn konkret für
erwartungen gehabt wenn sich eine partei
als islamisch bezeichnet was sie
explizit zwar nicht tut aber nicht
inhaltlich so dass die handlungen dieser
partei suchen auch nach dem islamischen
werten entsprechen
nicht nur dass man eben gegeben hat dass
die bevölkerung werde sich zweiter
klasse gefühlt hat jetzt ist es wahr
aber zum beispiel ein von einer
islamischen regierung vorsichtig
erwarten dass diese regierung korrupt
ist dass schmiergelder sage ich mal im
norden höhe herumgereicht werden und
eben eine von amgen hatte sich nur eine
periode wählen lassen
nach zwei jahren ein bekannter von mir
gesagt wenn ich könnte müsste ich jetzt
aussteigen weil ich kann das nicht mehr
aushalten und dann hat er dann in den
dritten in der vierten minute nicht mehr
erinnern lassen also das heißt die leute
die auch mit der gleichen erwartung
gegangen sind kommen gesehen
die korruption ist übermacht geworden
die vetternwirtschaft hat jetzt die
überhand genommen und all diese ist
natürlich für mich als ein moslem der
versuch zu praktizieren
mit meinen islamischen merkel nicht
vereinbar geschweige denn allgemeine
demokratie gestorbenen allgemeine
menschenrechte gedanken feiertag
erachten sie jetzt als ich sage jetzt
mal etwas gut gläubig wenn sich eine
partei zwar sozusagen das islamische
label gibt und vordergründig auch
symbolhaft auf die islamischen werte
setzt also das kopftuch beispielsweise
wieder erlaubt in den in der
öffentlichen sphäre der staatlichen
sphäre die privilegien für die
kemalistisch ausgerichteten erlebten
sozusagen abschafft und man dann aber im
nachhinein eigentlich merkt das war viel
verpackung aber wenig inhalt dieser
debatte gab es von anfang an es gab sehr
viele zweifel schon 2002 2003 was
eigentlich überhaupt jetzt mit der
türkei passieren wird in dem nun eine
regierung kommt dieselbe aus einer
tradition partei tradition kommt die
eine sehr starke an islamistische agenda
hatte in der zeit und das spiegelt schon
auch so dass die atmosphäre in zeit
kreis von dieser zeit wieder was herr
hatte polo gerade dargelegt hat war eine
schon eine hoffnung da dass die akp
regierung in den ersten jahren gemeinsam
in einem bündnis mit verschiedensten
gesellschaftlichen gruppen es gab ja
viele liberale progressive die ja auch
damals 2002 2003 2004 bis 2005 würde ich
sagen 2004 sehr stark auch eine hoffnung
gehegt haben dass die schon immer sehr
stark gottéron strukturen dass sie
starke macht des militärs die sich zu
sehr in die politik eingemischt hat und
in die zivilgesellschaft dass diese
krankheitsbilder der türkischen
demokratie
die ja schon die noch nie sehr gut
funktioniert hat das muss man sich
natürlich auch daran erinnern ja das
natürlich wenn heute wir sprechen wir
immer über die regierung erdogan
sprechen aber natürlich gab es ja schon
großes problem auch vorher die hoffnung
war das eben mit der entlastung dieses
kemalistischen erbes und der
demokratisierung die dadurch entstehen
könnte dass sozusagen eine neue eine
konsolidierung der demokratie passiert
wo es dann nicht nur einfach um die
gewaltenteilung geht sondern sich
wirklich auch gesellschaftlich in den
institutionen sich niederlassen das
problem war das dann tatsächlich ab 2005
zu beobachten ist dass die akp dann
diese bündnisse zunehmend aufgegeben hat
und ihr stärke sie in den wahlen wurden
zerrte er bis zu den bis 2015 hat er
kontinuierlich auch ihre machtbasis
ausbauen können je stärker sie wurde
umso stärker kam dann auch eine agenda
zum vorschein die schon immer so als
eine hidden agenda diskutiert worden ist
ich würde sagen wenn wir heute
rückblickend hätte es vielleicht auch
anders laufen können also ich denke 2005
war schon ein wichtiger moment
wir wissen nicht was passiert wäre wenn
die eu tatsächlich mehr schritte auf die
türkei zu dem zeitpunkt als sie
tatsächlich verformen unternommen hat
was dann passiert wäre also ironischer
und tragischerweise ist ja jetzt 2015
wurde der flüchtling stil mit die
flüchtlings kooperation mit der türkei
vereinbart zu einem zeitpunkt als die
menschenrechtslage desaströses selber in
der türkei war also es gibt also ein
sehr problematisches ungleichgewicht
auch in diesem verhältnis und dem wissen
nicht was passiert wäre wenn tatsächlich
noch stärker dieser weg hinsichtlich der
reformen zu einer mitgliedschaft in eu
gegangen wäre aber jetzt sind wir an
einem punkt wo diese regierung
tatsächlich die alten strukturen des
journalismus weitgehend aufgehoben hat
und sie nun mit der eigenen autorität
füllt und das ist natürlich das bittere
das traurige das nun erdogans regierung
genau diejenigen reform rückgängig mache
die sie ja selber eingeleitet hat ja und
das ist natürlich wirklich schade und
wird sicher jeden der daran glaubt dass
islam und demokratie nicht vereinbar
ein großes reservoir an empirischen
beweisen geben
wasser auf die mühlen jener die das
wasser haben dass sich schon seit jeher
nicht vereinbar gewesen
hertha jalousie hat mir auch berichtet
dass es beispielsweise ihre beiden
schwestern die kopftuch tragen ebenfalls
hier in der schweiz benachteiligung
erfahren also das zeigt dass sozusagen
hier bei uns jetzt die ähnlichen
diskussionen und ähnlichen muster
ablaufen die in der türkei zu diesen
problemen führen wenn sie in
diskussionen in öffentlichen oder auch
im umfeld in ihrem umfeld in diskussion
verwickelt werden und die menschen
fragen was macht denn eine akp wählbar
was macht die denn gutes was erzählen
sie dann den leuten also muss ich sagen
dass meine mutter meine eine meiner
schwestern täter ein kopftuch also was
macht die akw will was ich hier auch
zurück auf meiner arbeiten oder ich
meine 1997 wurde ja das kopftuchverbot
an der universität in verfassungsmäßiger
in der türkei durchgesetzt und das hat
viele muslime als junge muslime eine
theaterausbildung verwehrt in der türkei
und das verbot wieder hass 2010
aufgehoben also 13 jahre lang und
selbstverständlich wenn jetzt eine
partei kommt die dieses verbot aufhebt
und die mädchen die möglichkeit
ermöglicht oder das hat auswirkungen und
das macht natürlich sinn passieren also
generiert sympathisieren ihr in europa
auch also in die türkei 10 dollar
braucht aber das ausschlaggebend war zum
beispiel das flüchtlings stil oder mit
der türkei also ich meine jetzt den
zustand sorgt dass der fall weil das man
hätte man kein flüchtling stil gemacht
hatte aber ich glaube es ist schon
irgendwie hat man das in kauf genommen
aber dass die türkei hat die flüchtlinge
diskussionslos aufgenommen also es war
von die akp hat das wirklich diskussion
sollen aufgenommen
eine million flüchtlingen das hat
natürlich auch sehr viel sympathisieren
generiert und das natürlich so faktor
und die war nicht ausschlaggebend sind
für die menschen
frau sie hatten eben schon angekündigt
so etwas wie geburtsgebrechen das ist
jetzt meine ausdrucksweise wie das
verhältnis das der staatlichen sphäre zu
den religiösen sphäre
der türkei von beginn weg ein thema war
und dazu schauen wir uns jetzt mal einen
einspieler die osmanen gründen im 13
jahrhundert aus einem kleinen
turkmenischen fürstentum in nord
anatolien das osmanische reich mitte des
16 jahrhunderts ist das reich auf dem
höhepunkt seiner macht
es erstreckt sich von afrika über asien
nach europa danach schrumpft das
osmanische reich nach dem ersten
weltkrieg bleibt nur ein rumpf gebilde
in anatolien übrig jetzt nimmt ein
osmanisches offizier mustafa kemal
atatürk den kampf auf er erobert gebiete
zurück die türkei in ihren heutigen
grenzen entsteht
1923 wird die türkische republik
ausgerufen
der präsident heißt mustafa kemal
atatürk er modernisiert die türkei nach
westlichem vorbild stellt die
religionsausübung unter kontrolle des
staates türkisch wird amtssprache die
arabische schrift durch die lateinische
ersetzt
bildung für alle auch für die mädchen
die frauen bekommen politische rechte
das tragen des kopftuchs in den
staatlichen institutionen wird verboten
auch die männer sollen die traditionelle
kopfbedeckung den face ablegen und
europäische hüte tragen
die türkei wird säkularer und
nationalistischer doch bis heute prallen
östliche tradition und westliche
lebensweise aufeinander
er hat die prognose waren in der wir uns
damals delegierter der diyanet der
staatlich religiösen behörde der türkei
die wird ja heute sehr stark kritisiert
vielleicht noch stärker in deutschland
als der große bekannte die tib verband
in österreich als a tip und bei uns als
die ja nicht einfach tisch dies in form
der stiftung genau die
türkisch-islamische stiftung schweiz
welche rolle hat aus ihrer sicht die
diyanet damals gehabt bei der
staatsgründung und wie hat sich
möglicherweise ihre rolle auf vereinbar
also wenn wenn wenn ich 40 jahre zurück
gehe dann hat es noch keine imame
gegeben die aus der türkei hierher kamen
also als folge von diane amateure haben
immer rolle übernommen seien aus der ja
das waren natürlich bedürfnis dass
ausgebildete imame theologen quasi diese
aufgabe auch wahrnehmen sollten dann hat
das angefangen
der name zu schicken zuerst mit bis zu
20 personen war die kontingent wurde das
erhöht und so weiter das war mal eine
dienstleistung nicht nur der
türkischstämmigen natürlich wurde selbst
nicht wirken aber wenn wir auch
heutzutage in der moschee schauen wo
dann von durch die vereine betrieben
werden
alle kohle von jedem land muss lieber zu
sehen also kommt aber kommt albana alle
und das ist wie er sein sollte und das
war gut und deswegen seine zeit als
davids gegrillt werden sollte als erste
islamische dachverband wurde ich von den
dreien hat seine zeit angefragt ihre
delegierte zu sein ihre vertretung zu
sein welche ich dann angenommen hatte
ich habe auch versucht die probleme die
dann damals die immer mehr mit
bewilligungen arbeit bildung und so
weiter haben zu lösen als die formalen
probleme oder innerhalb von meinem
problem also arbeitsbewilligung und
einreise usw
die imame es gab damals noch keine
kritik seitens der bevölkerung an den
predigten wie das heute ist und dass sie
nicht deutsch sprechen richtig damals
war das noch
waren diese probleme nicht noch mal froh
dass ausgeben desto look und da waren
dass sie der gesellschaft helfen und
damals auch die imame mit denen hatte
ich häufige kontakte gehabt waren auch
integrationsfördernd also wir haben auch
positiv sich quasi der gesellschaft
beigetragen
ungefähr neben dann haben sie gesagt
dass wir zum beispiel in der moschee in
vivi geben im koran unterricht aber eben
wir müssen auch unseren platz in der
gesellschaft nehmen in der richtung weil
sie die sprache nicht kannten haben sie
die predigten nicht halten können weil
sie dann nur für vier jahre da sind dann
wieder zurückgehen dann haben sie auch
keine lust gehabt die sprache zu lernen
also von systems ist thematisch hat es
ein problem gegeben aber sie haben in
ihrem positiven beitrag geleistet bis
eben leider sie dann diese rolle nicht
mehr hatten weil mit der zeit was in
deutschland mit ditib so stark geworden
ist ist auch irgendwie leicht hier
erschienen wir haben in den schweizer
medien erfahren dass auch der dialog
hiergegen zum beispiel gülen-bewegung
einen bericht fasst hat und geschickt
hat also geheim
im september 2016 und ich verstehe ich
lebe seit über 50 jahren in der schweiz
ich besuche immer wieder die türkei
aber seit 2000 sich sehen verstehe ich
meine landsleute in der türkei nicht
mehr so wohl auch hier warum weil dies
ist eine islamische ist sage ich mal
einrichtung wo vorbeter bestand von
wiedergibt eine woche später am 20
september kommt anscheinend ein ordner
von ankara über die grünen bewegung zu
berichten
sieben tage später ging ein bericht raus
die bericht wurde in den schweizer
zeitungen publiziert welche dann über
österreich kam es in dem bericht
es ist schlimm genug dass der die annett
nachrichtendienstlicher tätigkeiten
macht es ist schlimm genug
agententätigkeit wahrgenommen wird von
einem islamischen inklusion noch was ihn
dann besteht lügen verwendungen das habe
ich nicht mehr verstanden nur zwei
beispiele zu mehreren in dem bericht
steht dass die grünen bewegung mit geld
medien beeinflusst und gegen die türkei
propaganda macht wäre sehr interessant
zu finden welche medien wie viel geld
bezahlt wurde
ein zweites beispiel die gülen-bewegung
hat und relativ geheime konten nicht nur
die gewinne von der schweiz sondern aus
der türkei und von anderen ländern
werden hier in den geheim kunden
gehalten wäre interessant zu wissen in
der bank und das wird unterschrieben vom
stadtbetrieb einwilligung sagte schenk
also das heißt ein imam
das war anscheinend nicht da wäre dann
lustig quasi stellvertretend ein
vorbeter verfasst eine solche pflicht
und abschickt ein theologe ein vorbeter
so etwas also mindestens mal sollte
geschickt werden und was richtig ist
jetzt müssen wir vielleicht hält zur
klärung für die zuschauenden zuschauer
sagen dass die pille in bewegung zeigt
den putschversuch für diesen
putschversuch verantwortlich gemacht
worden ist und seither eben auch als
terrororganisation in der türkei gilt
was sie jetzt geschildert haben würde
dafür sprechen und besteht
das was ich sage jetzt auch vom
schweizer von deutscher seite auch immer
wieder angesprochen wird dass die diane
zu einem verlängerten arm der politik an
groß geworden ist werden sie denn zum
stimmen sie sind ja vorstandsmitglied
der basler muslim kommission die der
dachverband der muslimischen
organisation ist sehen sie das so oder
können sie nichts anfangen zum vorwurf
also ich kann also jetzt bmk cell
modifiziert ja nur die bastel muslime
also wir haben ja mit jeanette zwar
keine zusammenarbeit und dem sind ja
keine die annett moschee kein sie hat
halt und kommission doch es gibt
eigentlich gar nicht am nahen moschee
jeden mann wird fügen gestellt von
jahren selber aber es ist ja nicht so
dass ich mein die basis muss die
kommission vertritt ja nicht nur
türkische muslime es wird ja auch als
einstimmiger beschluss liege also wir
sind eine vielfältige organisation die
aus verschiedenen kulturellen welt ganz
hat jetzt zu den vorwürfen ich kann dazu
geben keine stellung nehmen weil ich mit
diesem thema nicht vertraut bin ich habe
auch sagen wir mal journalist ich auch
nichts jetzt mitbekommen aber ich
vertraue uns ein rechtsstaat also wenn
hier aktionen stattfinden die das
gesetzte welchen da bin ich überzeugt
damit die behörden da aktiven werden
dass ich etwas unternehmen
also so dasitzt also dass er noch noch
schwierig also allein dieses verfassen
von berichten ist er noch kein
rechtsbruch aber trotzdem ist natürlich
die situation schwierig in deutschland
wird darüber diskutiert ob die ditib den
verfassungsschutz unterstellt werden
soll oder durch ihn beobachtet werden
soll
wie sehen sie das weiter was für eine
rolle hat die ja nicht heute
ich würde nicht sagen dass sie heute
eine sehr andere rolle hat als wie vor
20 jahren ich denke ein wichtiger punkt
ist hier
1980 der militärputsch in der türkei der
dass der dann dazu geführt hat dass eine
sogenannte türkisch islamische these zu
einem zweiten starts credo wurde also
jenseits des kemalismus noch diese these
sehr stark vertreten wurde und in der
zeit dort muss man ja dass vororten wie
dann die ditib und ideal hat sich dann
in deutschland und in anderen ländern
entwickelt hat es ist positiv dass sie
jetzt darüber gesprochen wird aber das
problem ist auf gar keinen fall neu
schon in den 80er jahren in den 90er
jahren gab es immer wieder fälle in
denen bekannt wurde dass von den
konsulaten aus bespitzelung gemacht wird
das eben auch den idealen eine sehr
politische einrichtung und keine
religiöse einrichtungen ist insbesondere
haben das immer wieder aleviten zur
sprache gebracht oder auch kunden die
die von diesen bespitzelung und von
diesen maßnahmen halt eben direkt
betroffen waren
dass wir heute jetzt darüber sprechen
vielmehr sprechen ist weil nun der
ehemalige koalitionspartner sozusagen
also der informelle verbündete der akp
regierung nämlich die gülen-bewegung nun
in einem bruder fest ist ja und jetzt
auch innerhalb der sunnitischen gruppe
nun eine gruppe gibt die von diesen
maßnahmen betroffen ist man kann eine
einfache medien recherche machen und
sehen dass diese kritiken über den
langen arm des staates schon in den
80ern gibt ja intensiviert hat sich das
jetzt eben dadurch dass seit 2001 den
anschlägen in den usa nun auch die
westeuropäischen staaten sich dem islam
sich zu wenden als eine religion die auf
grund der von migration eine beständige
rolle in europa spielen wird das ist
eine sehr späte erkenntnis bis 2001
haben alle westeuropäische staaten
selbst frankreich ja mit ihrem
sozialistischen ordnung
es erlaubt dass die herkunftsländer
moscheen betreiben und die religiösen
bedürfnisse der länder über der
migranten übernehmen weil die idee war
dass man das noch ein bisschen
outsourcen werden effektive bindungen
zwischen den migranten und den
herkunftsländern weiterhin stark
gehalten und vielleicht liegen sie ja
dann auch zurück oder man hat die
migration nicht als in beständiger
antrag
der gesellschaften gesehen der
muslimischen kasse deshalb haben sich
die europäischen börsen im rückblick
sie hat sich nicht mehr zurückgehalten
sie haben es explizit wurde die türkei
algerien dazu aufgefordert dass sie
diese maschinen einrichten und die
religiösen bedürfnisse dann sozusagen
bedienen über die konsulate dadurch hat
man natürlich als staat in einem
russischen staat enorme einflussbereiche
zugeteilt ohne dass man das eigentlich
wirklich wahrgenommen hat ja also was
dann tatsächlich in den konsulaten oder
dem musée passiert ist war fernab der
mehrheitsgesellschaft und heute ist das
eben anders heute gibt es wird sehr
genau hingeschaut tatsächlich so dass
die schweiz auch schon bestimmte
schritte auch schon unternommen hat auch
rechtliche als es um bespitzelung et
cetera gegen und in deutschland führt
das jetzt so eine sehr großen debatte
mit verfassungsschutz sicher beobachtung
es ist nun tatsächlich schon überfällig
zu überlegen wer eigentlich die
migranten diese migranten die jetzt sie
auch falsch von migranten zu sprechen da
sind ja auch schon viele kinder geboren
ja also wem diese gemeinde die gemeinden
die vor sechzig jahren nach europa
zurückgezogen ist die mir eigentlich zu
gehören ist es also eine aufgabe des
schweizerischen staates ist das die
aufgabe von deutschland diesen
religiösen bedürfnissen gerecht zu
werden oder es ist die aufgabe der
türkei und dass diane und das ist
einfach die kernfrage und ich denke in
allen westeuropäischen staaten ist
mittlerweile eine sehr große sorge auch
da und auch ein sehr aktives bestreben
nun in diesem bereich einzutreten also
das jetzt theologie islamische theologie
angeboten wird an einigen stunden
universitäten in deutschland hat er ihm
damit zu tun dass man ja selber
ausbilden möchte ja und das war nämlich
sehr lange ein enormer einflussbereich
dem der türkei gegeben wurde unter
absolutem wissen und fordern der
hiesigen starten
und jetzt ist ein spätes erwachen was
sie sagen das ist ein kleber je dass die
hiesigen die europäischen staaten die
zügel die sind üblich in die hand nehmen
sich also natürlich also wird das ist ja
die frage also warum soll also wenn
tatsächlich also
europäische staaten sind säkuläre
staaten ja es geht es sind keine
staatsreligion in dem sinne die die
anderen religionen trommel ausschließen
würde denken dass in ihren ohren sie hat
mir ja auch davon berichtet wie wichtig
sie die einrichtung der die einen finden
beispielsweise um die pkv zu
organisieren und für andere
dienstleistungen gleichzeitig sagten sie
aber in der moschee in der sie
eigentlich heimisch sind die war eine
der die zu militärisch gehört und eine
andere national nationalistisch
ausgerichteten gruppierung um sagten sie
möchten sich jetzt los lesen weil die
ihnen zu sehr auf die türkei
ausgerichtet sein ganzes können dann
haben sie große sympathien für das was
frau untersagt das sagt ja was soll ich
meine aber ich muss hier in einem punkte
sprechen ich sehe nicht dass die
europäische regierungen die zügel in die
hand nehmen wollen sondern ich sehe er
sie möchten den einfluss der türkei
beschenken zum beispiel keine auslands
finanzierung zu lassen aber gleichzeitig
hier wenig gegen für die anerkennung
auch kämpfen also so staatliche
anerkennung ist momentan ein no go das
wird sich ja nur als durchziehen also
durchgehend oder aber gleichzeitig auch
sagen die türkei darf hier nichts machen
oder und das ist für mich der falsche
angst hat und ich sehe die debatte er
wer in diesem rahmen weniger dass mehr
entgegenkommen ist es gibt gewisse
bestimmungen zb von unserer
regierungssitzung vom tisch sagt im
vorjahr sagt ein solcher weg
aufgeschlagen hat wo ich hier begrüße
aber auch der stößt auch widerstand so
beobachte ich das also da geht es um die
diskussion der öffentlich rechtlichen
anerkennung kleinen seen mehr sozusagen
thematisch und da wo die bedürfnisse
ganz offenkundig ins grün und sie
zugeständnisse machen ohne dass ein
juristischer status verändert würde ganz
genau das wäre ein anfang
wie sehen sie das herr hat die prognos
sie waren ja lange jahre auch im
interreligiösen diskussionen und in
verbindung auch mit diskussion der
kantonalen regierung als dachverbands
präsident
sehen sie die hiesige gesellschaft
verstärkt in der pflicht die religiösen
bedürfnisse der muslime auf sich zu
nehmen sag ich jetzt mal weil ich auch
dass immer noch dass es also eine würde
quasi gesehen wird und nicht wirklich
als
eine serviceleistung des staates gewesen
wenn ich das möchte ich noch etwas
präzisiert und zur vorherigen umfrage
ganz kurz die bilder in bewegung wurde
denn nicht erst mit dem putschversuch zu
terror ist das schon erklärt und ein
anderthalb monate vorher der nationale
sicherheitsrat wo erdogan und generäle
und innenministers verdanken ist
dabei ist die haben als empfehlung an
der regierung definiert und die haben
publik gemacht das ist sie an die
türkische regierung empfehlen würden wir
eine bewegung als terror-organisation
auch zu definieren und die erste
reaktion am folgenden tag kam von
deutschland deutschland gesagt haut also
irgendein rat kann nicht eine
organisation ohne gerichtliche
beweislage erklären und dann wurde dann
an der regierung nicht weiter
sogar der eu hat dann nochmals stark
betont definieren sie bei denen der
gesetzgebung was terrorismus ist welche
der türkei ist immer noch nicht gemacht
hat das ist glaube ich ein globales
problem das jeder staat den terrorismus
für sich selbst definieren aber ich
möchte gerne jetzt noch nicht zurück zu
der frage welche aufgabe sehen sie denn
richtig
ich denke in die schweiz sind wie in
vielen anderen ländern in einer sehr
positiven lage insofern dass die muslime
nicht in den ghettos leben
die muslime sind bereit sich zu
integrieren mehrheitlich und aber dem
klima haben immer wieder sage ich mal
enttäuschungen erlebt zum beispiel eben
keine koranschulen abstimmung im kanton
zürich hat ziemlich wehgetan seine zeit
weil damals war eben die ersten die die
änderung der verfassung kantonale
verfassung sowohl als auch die
öffentlich-rechtliche anerkennung
anderer religionsgemeinschaften war
diskutiert und das wurde dann
nicht akzeptiert so wären hat mit 23 53
prozent abgelehnt und das hat den
muslimen quasi die hoffnung sich stark
zurückgeworfen und mit
öffentlich-rechtliche an regierung
wirklich sagt man den muslimen okay ihr
seid eine gemeinde die hier angekommen
seid vieler muslime sehen so ich bin ein
teil der gesellschaft ich bin integriert
ich bin eventuell erstrangig es
schweizer und bahn muss nimmt wie alle
anderen alle sind schweiz sondern
protestant katholisch und so weiter ich
bin auch schweizer und band moslem
denken viele muslime wenn nicht alle
und die stehen vor der tür die werden
nicht hineingelassen genau also ich
denke wir sind hier bereits den übergang
zu einem ganz wichtigen thema nämlich es
gibt eine gewisse überlappung zwischen
den türkei diskurs und dem islam diskurs
und viele muslime sind sich einig in der
schweiz auch in deutschland dass sie
sich ausgegrenzt fühlen nicht als
türkinnen und türken sondern als muslime
und musliminnen wie stark ist die
islamdebatte eigentlich auch grund für
das junge türkinnen und türken sich
vielleicht stärker einem einem
konservativen islam oder einer zuwendung
zum konservativen türkischen islam in
der form von von von der akp zu wenden
und sich dort besser abgefüllt abgehoben
also es ist es ist die ablehnung also
jetzt zurück zu der anderen fall wo sie
gefragt haben oder meine mutter und
meine schwester und ich hab selber
erlebt also sie tagen hier ein kopftuch
ein religiöses symbol
und es wird ja auch in der
öffentlichkeit immer wieder wahrgenommen
und auch sie werden wir gegen
anfeindungen innerhalb der gesellschaft
weil sie ein kopftuch tragen in der vom
schlimmsten immer dann wenn irgendwelche
terroranschläge im ausland passieren
oder von den islamisten dann sind sie
auch im bisher hier von der bevölkerung
und dann gibt es natürlich auch ein
erdbeer oder der wir als schutz steht
für muslime konservative muslime oder
und das zieht natürlich an und es
eigentlich verdient für die gesellschaft
weil die ablehnung
natürlich dann die gedanken auch spielen
lässt ja nicht vielleicht nicht wie
kommen vielleicht gehe ich doch in die
türkei war man ja mich willkommen jetzt
obwohl man eigentlich hier integriert
ist ein teil der gesellschaft ist und
ich finde das schon sehr kritisch die
diskussion in deutschland gegen ja
damals hoch um den fußballer mesut özil
wo genau die diskussion stattfand wie
stark bin ich zugehörig als deutsch
türke sozusagen schon nur diese wort
konstruktion ist ja an sich interessant
und wie stark bin ich dann trotzdem
wieder nur in anführungszeichen türkise
die das freie tor
diese dritte generation der türken also
diese diskussion um bösel war insofern
interessant dass er sich ja dann
nochmals selber hineingebracht hat und
über rassismus gesprochen hat und ich
denke das ist jetzt ganz wichtig
vielleicht auch immer wirklich genau zu
gucken was ist das von dem phänomen dass
wir eigentlich beschreiben ja diese
ausgrenzung die erfahren wird wenn wenn
wenn ein kopftuch getragen wird oder
andere religiöse symbole zum ausdruck
kommt wird fassen wir unter islamophobie
sehr schnell auf und das ist auch
tatsächlich auch präsent wie sie wissen
dass man medienanalysen vielen vielen
anderen bereichen das ist tatsächlich
auch eine fahrbare diskriminierung und
ausgrenzung gibt kann es ganz furchtbar
und problematisch ist dass ein
ausländischer staatspräsident sozusagen
zum schutzpatron verteidiger von oder
anja kritiker des rassismus wird
insbesondere wenn es jemand ist er in
seinem eigenem land diese praktiken noch
viel stärker selber durchsetzt ja also
erdogan möchte keine assimilation der
migranten in europa er hat das mal als
ein menschen verbrechen bezeichnet er
möchte motor sprachlichen unterricht und
er möchte die religiöse rechte schützen
er gewährt sie den aleviten in der
türkei nicht aber er hat keinen
muttersprachlichen unterricht für die
kurden also all das was er kritisiert
wenn er in europa seine reden hält
praktiziert er noch zu einem viel
stärkeren gewalt vollem ausmaß in der
türkei und das ist das problem also die
stilisierung von einer opferrolle
passiert hat dann wenn das nur wenn die
kritik nur für den
eigenen fall zutrifft ja also nur für
die eigene betroffenheit und die kritik
dass man ausgegrenzt wird aufhört dann
wenn es um die rechte andere geht das
ist auch ein problem
ja wir hatten ja die ähnliche diskussion
auch mit dem mit dem der fall des
doppeladler zb in international man
genau diese fragen der zugehörigkeit
sind ganz ganz zentral ja denn es
eigentlich also begonnen hat das
natürlich schon von anfang an aber für
die generation die sogar hier geboren
und aufgewachsen ist ist das natürlich
eine sehr existenzielle das phänomen
und da geht es nicht darum ob man ein
kopftuch trägt und also sehr sehr
religiös ist man erfährt ihr diese
ausgrenzung auch als an eine wieder-
oder kurde in bestimmten feldern auch ja
nur ist natürlich diese diese aspekt
durch die regierung erdogan auch sehr
sehr explizit politisiert worden ja die
es wurde jetzt es gibt einen ministerium
das für die ein institut das für die
belange der auslandstürken eingesetzt
worden ist in 2010
immer wieder präsentiert sich auch
erdogan als ein sogenannter schutzpatron
für die marginalisierten und
entrechteten euro in europa und das
denke ich kann eben nur dann resonanz
haben wenn es nicht genügend politiker
und gesellschaftliche stimmen in der
schweiz in deutschland gibt die sich
selber stark machen gegen rassismus
gegen die diskriminierung ja ich denke
erdogan nutzt ein vakuum aus und hat so
viel widerhall auch weil diese debatte
tatsächlich nicht sehr laut zur sprache
kommen ja unter frei von dem doppeladler
als auch von oesede ging es ja darum
dass selbst sehr bekannte erfolgreiche
personen ja die ja schon viel geleistet
haben
ich denke nicht dass leistung liege ein
pro ein kriterium sein sollte jedes
mensch jeder mensch hat ein anrecht auf
respekt und inklusion natürlich ja
aber dort war deshalb besonders prägnant
wie schnell dann diese person doch der
türkei oder nicht zugehörig gesehen
werden natürlich ist da auch das eigene
verhalten von oehsen auch ein wichtiger
diskussionspunkt aber grundsätzlich geht
es wirklich die kernfrage in dieser
debatte ist sind diese
schweiz töten deutsch türken sind das
schweizer sind aus deutschen nicht nur
von sich selber aus wie sie sich selber
zuzuschreiben sondern begreift die
gesellschaft auch das wirklich als ihre
diese person als ihre vollwertigen
mitbürger
ja und wenn wenn sie das tun dann hat
das konsequenzen auf bildungspolitik auf
religionen auf allen möglichen ebenen in
der gesellschaft es kann nicht nur dann
diskutiert werden wenn es gerade wieder
ein problem gibt ja das muss proaktiv
geschehen nicht reaktiv euro kennen sie
das dass das gefühl sich entscheiden zu
müssen ich bin entweder schweizer basler
oder türke also sagen primär basler das
ist so meine identität stiftend für mich
und sekundär bin ich doppelbürger und
ich beteilige mich in diese diskussion
nie weil ich sage immer ich habe die
zwei heimat ich habe die schweiz und die
türkei und mein anliegen ist es dass es
beiden gut geht oder dass es beide von
dem beziehungen profitieren und beide
die menschenrechte in beiden staaten
funktioniert dass niemand diskriminiert
wie es egal ob er alle wie zune oder
konfessionslos ist und das für tätig ist
befinden sie sich denn von beiden
heimaten auch ganz angenommen
ich habe das für gelegt dass ich meinen
weg gegangen ich habe ich alles der
schweizer bevölkerung zu verdanken unter
den filmen hier die haben jetzt alles
ermöglicht also ich kann sagen ja ich
bin ein vollwertiges mitglied dieser
gesellschaft
das kann ich aber nur für mich selber
behalten ich sehe natürlich dass meine
mutter oder meine schwester mit anderen
problemen zu kämpfen haben das verletzt
mich natürlich dass jemand zu beobachten
aber was mich selbst kann ich sagen ich
bin als man also würde ich bin weil ich
keine wirklich da kein religiöses symbol
tage bin ich auch anerkannt wir sind
schon fast am schluss der sendung zum
schluss würde mich einfach von ihnen
allen noch interessieren
wie sehen sie die entwicklung jetzt
unter den türkischstämmigen menschen im
ausland in der schweiz
wie wird sich die lage verändern gibt es
einen dialog oder wird ein dialog
angestrebt zwischen den
unterschiedlichen parteien und
ausrichtungen
diese tiefe kluft zu überwinden ich
denke das muss sein
also ich selbst gibt es keine chance
also aber eben die wille muss auch
vorhanden sein das erste und ich denke
man hat das mal einmal praktiziert in
einem kleineren sinne als der zbw orts
gegründet wurde sehr unterschiedliche
ansichten große spannungen in der türkei
usw
wir haben gesagt die spannungen
zugelassen dort wiesen die schweiz wir
haben gemeinsame interessen hier der
mine selben probleme müssen wir lösen
und sehr damals in dem kontext waren
alle dabei also die alemannia alle
gruppen und nicht nur alle anderen
muslimischen seite auch also das heißt
wenn die der wille da ist kann man das
auch praktizieren sogar es ist damals
wir haben nicht geglaubt dass alle
muslimischen konnten weil auch damals in
deutschland probleme gegeben hat und so
das heißt man hat vorgezeigt man kann es
schaffen und ich denke das ist der weg
also wie müssen die einflüsse vom
angestammten ländern wirklich begrenzen
eliminieren wenn möglich und sagen okay
du machst dieser partei sein oder du
machst dann lassen wir mal außerhalb der
moschee
was deshalb unseren vereinen unsere
gesellschaft wie sind muslime in der
schweiz & ba dass wir nicht nur für uns
selbst von den auch für die nächsten
generationen weil wir das beste
organisieren können ist es wichtig ich
denke dass das jetzt eine sehr spannende
phase die alle verschiedenen diversen
akteure und gruppen von neuen
herausforderungen aufgaben stellt und
ich sehe das eigentlich als ein sehr
vielschichtiges bild
die aleviten über die wir wenig
gesprochen haben erfahren haben wir eine
ganz andere erfahrung in den letzten
jahren gemacht sie erfahren sie es gibt
eine anerkennung für sie in basel zum
beispiel und auch in den anderen
in deutschland in andere in einigen
bundesländern und sie erfahren eine
anerkennung und stärkung die sie an der
türkei gar nicht haben
ähnlich ist auch mit den kurden und das
ist natürlich eine ganz spannende
konstellation was das dann für die
beziehungen innerhalb der diversen
gruppen bedeutet in der schweiz haben
wir ein sehr interessantes verhältnis
das umgekehrte mehrheits im internet
verhalten das ergibt die schweiz ist das
einzige land wo die hkb sehr schlechte
werte erhält und die opposition sehr
hohe werte erhält man sieht die schweiz
ist das doch ein sehr interessantes
laboratorium zugucken kann auch hier
vielleicht eine neue beziehung entstehen
und ich denke das wird unter anderen
voraussetzungen stattfinden denn hier
müssen sich die kurden oder die arminia
oder die aleviten nicht sich verstecken
ja und das ist sehr spannend zu
beobachten
gut ich denke wir werden die situation
weiterhin auch im auge behalten und ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen für dieses
gespräch
anfang november diskutieren wir in der
sternstunde religion ein brisantes thema
es geht um die streitfrage abtreibung
was ist die haltung in den verschiedenen
religionsgemeinschaften dazu wer
entscheidet was zulässig ist
sie können bei der diskussion live dabei
sein im haus der religionen in bern
mehr informationen dazu finden sie unter
der eingeblendeten adresse und jetzt
gleich geht's hier weiter mit der
sternstunde philosophie mein kollege
yves bost diskutiert mit grellem exten
den ehemaligen generalsekretär des club
of rome
[Musik]